[موسيقى]
عمليه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في مخيم جنين
حلقه من سلسله لا تنتهي من استهداف
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في المدينه ومخيم
اللاجئين بها فالمقاومه في جنين ذات تباع
طويل في مواجهه الاحتلال وذات تنوع فصائل
لافذ يظهر في الاستهداف الاسرائيلي
لرموزها الميدانيه من الفصائل الفلسطينيه
بجنين كتائب شهداء الاقصى الذراع العسكريه
لحركه فتح والتي ينتمي اليها ضباط في
اجهزه الامن الفلسطينيه تتعقبهم القوات
الاسرائيليه قتلا او اعتقالا ومن الفصائل
النشطه في جنين كتائب القسام التابعه
لحركه حماس التي اعلنت مسؤولياتها عن عدد
من العمليات في مناطق مختلفه ضد الضفه من
احدث فصائل المقاومه والاكثر بروزا كتيبه
جنين التي ظهرت عام 2021 على واقع العدوان
الاسرائيلي على غزه وتتالف من مقاومين
ينتمون لاكثر من فصيل ابرازها سرايا القدس
التابعه لحركه الجهاد والحاضره ايضا بوضوح
في المقاومه بمخيم جنين والتي اعلن
الاحتلال انه يستهدف افرادها في اقتحامه
الاخير لكتيبه جنين علاقات وطيده وتنسيق
اللافت مع مجموعه عرين الاسود في نابلس
وهي من الفصائل الحديثه بالضفه خارج
الخريطه الفصاليه الفلسطينيه التقليديه
ويعد القضاء عليها احد اهم اولويات القوات
الاسرائيليه